the magic of this show is the ups and
the Downs unfortunately but the
authenticity of the show where people
really talk about their real lives and
their feelings is what keeps people
engaged and there's a lot of people that
have tried to mimic us and try to create
shows but without the authenticity a
real friendship that's why it hurts
that's why people bled for Ariana
because they were invested in real
relationships and that's what life's
about Lisa Vanderpump and Ariana Maddox
addressing scandaval at the White House
Correspondents Dinner in DC
so excited to be here this is such a
thrill
to this it's truly a once in a lifetime
opportunity and a moment that I've
honestly like dreamed of I've watched
this correspondence that are on
television the coverage every year and
so to be able to be here is really
really incredible it's a rough time but
let's be honest so this is the highlight
of what has been a bad experience yeah
that bad experience still playing out on
season 10 of Vanderpump Rules as viewers
will soon see the aftermath of Ariana
learning her boyfriend of nearly a
decade Tom Sandoval secretly carried out
a seven month affair with their co-star
Raquel Levis open relationships are tall
this is a full-blown love affair I wish
we both would have tried harder you
don't deserve one clean tier of mine
you want anything
for you to die
and in the two months since learning
about it Ariana says she's also learned
something about herself that I can do
anything I can handle anything yeah
that's good I would say something much
rude but I'm gonna leave it at that she
doesn't look like she's hurting now
cameras went back up to capture the
Fallout from the affair but the signs
were there all along fans now shocked by
The Moments filmed Last Summer
and according to Lisa there are more
shocks to come in the final episodes all
of it
believe it at that I think yeah
yeah I can't believe what that Tom sound
of our head Raquel however when Ariana's
away I know in the jacuzzis
seems like the ladies time in DC was the
perfect distraction from the drama they
even got one-on-one time with first lady
Jill Biden yes you did yes we did and
she was just so so kind and so generous
and so sweet
um yeah she took her time and she was
everything that you would want a first
lady to be
[Music]